willkommen zu einem neuen sendung von
philo es diesmal zum thema georgs emails
philosophie ich begrüße mit einer
doktorandin aus bonn hallo melanie erste
frage wäre die worin besteht ganz
allgemein gesagt die aktualität georg
simmel der ist ja nicht so bekannt da
stimmt es nicht so bekannt und vor allen
dingen nicht in der philosophie
neben er in der soziologie naja also
simmel ist zusammen mit weber und
turnier von der begründer der modernen
soziologie und worin die aktualität
besteht es ist dass er einen ganz
modernen begriff von gesellschaft hat
also er spricht nicht von der
gesellschaft das wäre etwas festes
sondern fang vergesellschaftung ein
prozess sozusagen genau also das von
innen dem wort selber ist dieser prozess
drin unterhalten individuum und
gesellschaft hängen untrennbar
miteinander zusammen
und was das individuum ist bestimmt sich
demnach auch ständig neue gegen die
video und prägen die gesellschaft und
umgekehrt trägt die gesellschaft auch
die individuum und wer zur gesellschaft
gehört das verändert sich ständig er hat
da eben den schmelztiegel großstadt vor
augen erleben war natürlich vor allen
dingen seine seine heimat berlin und
dort sieht er dass die verschiedenen
nationalitäten und lebensformen dort zu
einander treffen und einen stetigen
wechsel sich miteinander befinden also
ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen so ein
wunschdenken dass sich dann die
nationalen charakter oder die volks
geister irgendwie auflösen in diesem
prozess darin besteht sicherlich auch
eine aktualität das ist ja im zeitalter
der globalisierung genau das hätte er
damals noch nicht in der form auf dem
schirm aber ist da was das angeht schon
irgendwie ein vordenker der mann so
schriften dienst nie die philosophie des
geldes oder auch die großstädte und das
geistesleben da sehen wir dass ich
eigentlich so viel gar nicht verändert
hat jetzt hast du ein werk schon erwähnt
philosophie des geldes ja das ist recht
bekannt ich kenne es zudem
worum vorüber geht es dort in diesem
werk was ist die philosophie des geldes
gibt was was soll das eigentlich
naja die philosophie des geldes das ist
schon so ein bisschen problematisch mit
dem titel er hatte erst mal vor das
ganze psychologie des geldes und hat das
denn hinterher film so viele stellen ist
ein ganz und es ist ein werk das sehr
psychologisch anfängt oder sagt
psychologe philosophisch den erstellt am
anfang die frage was es wert warum
finden wir etwas wertvollen ja und weil
wir etwas wertvoller finden wollen wir
es haben sie bekommen und so entsteht
dann langsam so etwas wie eine vor
kapitalistische gesellschaft als er
begeht letztendlich vielleicht auch
anthropologisch könnte man das war den
anthropologischen konstanten der mensch
der villa und dadurch kommen eben dinge
in schwung
das ist eben auch eine grundthese dieses
werkes man kann insofern sagen dass das
geld zusammen mit mode so eine art oder
auch individualismus oder treibstoff der
moderne bildet als er sieht das geld und
die moderne kapitalistische gesellschaft
deswegen nicht mich negativ sondern er
sagt das geld befreit
während man in mittelalterlichen
lebensverhältnissen an die kunden
gewohnt natürliches natürlich werben
habe mandanten mit dem geld die
möglichkeit sich frei zu kaufen und sich
dann auch sozial neu zu assoziieren
das nennt er soziale differenzierung
sieht ja auch eine gewisse dialektik in
dieser befreiung also wir sind
einerseits frei von etwas könne aber
nicht gerade durch das geld auch wieder
umfragen
genau das sieht dann natürlich auch dann
das geld fließt ja auch jemanden aus der
eben
das geld eben nicht hatten oder nicht
macht das gilt nicht macht ja den augen
und insofern er charakterisiert hier
ganz verschiedene typen wie er sagt wir
sind alle abhängig vom geld keiner kann
sich davon frei schnell selbst der
heilige franziskus schafft es nicht denn
er setzt sich auch in bezug zum
kapitalismus in dem er das komplett
ablehnt das ist denn dialektisch wieder
daran gebunden ist das was ich besonders
ablehne das schleppe ich doch dann immer
noch nicht sich trotzdem sitzen und da
hat er in verschiedenen typen die er
dann also psychologisiert
charakterisiert das ist dann das ist
dann der verschwende zb das ist das
einzige das ist aber auch der blasierte
der sagt das bedeutet mir alles nicht so
richtig was jetzt hast du ein brief
begriff gebracht dass blasiert wenn ich
mich recht erinnere hatte diesen begriff
auch in seiner soziologie philosophie
das großstadtleben die anfrage kannst du
über seine philosophische analyse oder
psychologische soziologische analyse des
großstadtlebens noch etwas sagen ist es
noch aktuell auf die heutige zeit auf
jeden fall ist das aktuell also er hat
immer diese entgegensetzen dorf und
stadt und er sagt das dörfliche leben
ist dadurch bestimmt dass wir hier so
eine art homogene mal haben ja der
mensch im dorf der ist aufgehoben
in dieser dorfgemeinschaft überschaubar
die bei krediten genau
man kennt den postboten man kennt den
bus fahren und hat zu all diesen
menschen irgendwie eine persönliche
beziehung und er beschreibt das dann
auch in einer anderen schrift zum
fremden das fremde kommt in diese in
diese dörfliche gemeinschaft und ist nur
deswegen fremd weil die gemeinschaft ihm
entgegen stehen
in der großstadt gibt es diese form von
fremdheit gar nicht weil dort im grunde
genommen jeder dem anderen fremd denn in
den bus steigen dann kenne ich den
busfahrern ich kenne auch die anderen
nicht und diese ganzen gesichter die ich
nicht kenne
die will ich irgendwie ausblendung
heutzutage würde man sagen die kopfhörer
richtig oder smartphone per smartphone
und da sagt simmel diese ganzen
gesichter die rufe stress hervor
die machen
mit uns die lassen uns nicht unbeteiligt
und deswegen weil sie stress hervor
rufen muss der großstädter um sich zu
schützen eben zum glatten haben passiert
ist dass das was wir heute cool nennen
würden oder ist es doch etwas anders
könntest du den begebe hast du
vielleicht vor 20 jahren cool bin okay
also bis die gleichgültigkeit würdest du
auch sagen eine gewisse arroganz eine
gewisse also eine differenz er sagt dass
von außen diese plagiiert hat als auch
ganz wahrgenommen wird oder als kälte
der dorfbewohner der kommt in die
gestaltung der wundert sicht hat man
müssten sich die leute machen die das
nicht aber dann in dem sinne sagt die
großstadt schafft ebenso ein riesen raum
in dem jeder jeden fremd ist muss man
also will man das auch gar nicht man
will auch nicht jedes den meisten
prinzip stress auf der anderen seite das
positive ist aber dass sich nicht jeder
zeit sozial neue assoziieren kann also
in dieser ganzen einer seiner lehrer ist
nur zwei wurf und der denkt noch also
monats das ist ein völlig verliert ihr
vorgänger der soziologie kann man sagen
und er denkt in diesen großen entitäten
volk familie also objektiv ist eine bio
ein objektiver geil das sogar absolut
absoluter geistig hat er nicht mehr
von der volkskammer gräfenberg das sind
die frage was hält uns alle als
volksgemeinschaft zusammen das ist mitte
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts das
natürlich eine brandaktuelle wagen war
ja und da sagt sie in der buchstadt im
schmelztiegel bürstadt spielen diese
fielen diese ja diese althergebrachten
einheiten gar nicht mehr so eine rolle
sondern da geht es um ganz andere dinge
da geht es um lebensform
da geht es um zugehörigkeiten in
vereinen einen freundschafts kreisen ja
ich kann mich scheiden lassen nicht nur
heiraten also nicht jederzeit neu sozial
assoziiert und das schafft natürlich
auch eine gewisse freiheit ja die man
eben sonst nicht hat aber wahrscheinlich
wie im falle des geldes auch wieder eine
gewisse unfreiheit dieses großstadtleben
ist bestimmt zweischneidiges führt
vielleicht auch zu einer vereinzelung
das mache ich ganz zurückzieht anonym
wird niemand interessiert sich vereinen
franz kafka hat ist ja auch sehr
beeindruckend dann beschrieben und das
problem des relativismus kommt dann
alles ist gleichwertig alles ist
vielleicht auch nicht so nihilismus
realismus würde ich vielleicht nicht
sagen aber es hat schon das problem des
moralischen relativismus da eben dann
hier ja alle diese gruppen auf ihre
eigene ihre eigenen werte haben diese
werte aber auch gegenseitig also die
auch bestehen und soll koexistieren ist
muss nach konflikt in notwendiger weise
also man kann vielleicht eher sagen wir
statt relativismus den begriff benutzt
er tatsächlich ja von so einer art
trainer journalismus merkel also alles
steht mit allem in einer relation und
was war ist das kann man gar nicht
bestimmen das muss man in einem
relativen konnten
das ist relativ ja wenn man die vielen
dank da haben wir jetzt wirklich tiefe
einblicke erhalten in die philosophische
soziologische relevanz von georg sie mit
vielen dank nochmal ich sage auch
tschüss bis zur nächsten folge